what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos as you guys already know if
you have watched two or more of my lives
and you do not subscribe we have beef
okay beef people a couple announcements
before we start the show the first being
that we have two clips channels the
first is Pearl daily and the second is
just pearly Clips make sure you go
subscribe to both I think we're almost
at 200k on just pearly Clips so thank
you guys for that go subscribe
um also guys there are four membership
tiers that we have the first membership
tier lets you be a part of our chat the
second half of the show the second tier
um you get to be a part of our Discord
and our behind the scenes Vlogs third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media that means having access to
my inbox and the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
lot of people that want to grow on
social media
um sign up for this also you know some
people have questions behind the scenes
about the show so sign up for that
also guys um I got banned on Instagram
I know I know
um and so
um go follow my new
ton followers it's just pearly things
one and go follow my fifth and sixth
Tick Tock accounts because I took away
my first second third and fourth so it's
just pearly things dot five and six and
y'all are so great they repost so many
of my Clips on Tick Tock so that it's
like they can take me off the app but
you can't get rid of me you can't get
rid of me you can't okay thank you guys
for 700k we just hit that um like a
couple days ago so thank you 700k
again it's mad um that happened in like
seven months so it's actually insane
that you guys helped us do that
um also guys go subscribe to wife school
as you already know if you are a 304 if
you were at 304 and you want to be a
wife sign up for wife school go
subscribe to um wife School basically
where we um do lessons on like different
wifey stuff and we have wives come in
and teach you know turn a home and do a
housewife anyways
[Laughter]
um anyways anyways
um I think that's all if you guys want
to come on the show DM the pregame show
podcast uh on Instagram and
um all super chats go to blessing
getting a monopod am I saying yeah
blessings getting a monopod okay so um
today we have a huge panel lovely panel
um so why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age your relationship
status and a fun fact about yourself so
we're gonna start here go that way and
then second row
um I'm Emma I'm 23 years old I'm
originally Dutch
um I'm a singer and I'm single
hi I'm Sean
um 29 and what else were there fun fact
about you I'm single and I don't know
what's your what's your what's your job
um I'm a massage therapist and then and
you've been on big brother
I've been at me on the show as well oh
cool cool fun facts I'm Paris I'm 30 and
in my spare time I liked a game
I'm in zingo I'm 27
um I'm from Southeast London that's my
fun fact okay
I'm 27 I'm from Southeast London fun
facts uh I played uh college soccer in
the states for four years
okay I'm Angie I'm 23.
um I'm single I live in East my fun fact
is I'm an engineer in training
okay second row yeah okay I am on BK f81
um
and I'm from Birmingham and fun fact um
co-host on The Counter Culture podcast
world
[Laughter]
of League 29 also from Birmingham
um fun fact about me I once had a
football injury and I couldn't walk for
a year almost
I'm Eleanor I'm 27 and I'm from Barnsley
fun facts about me I brought my elbow
doing a tick tock once
he was hilarious
yeah Miracle I'm 26. fun fact about me I
can't remember one right now about doing
a podcast I might remember
over here
okay so today's topic um is
I think I titled it can modern women be
happy without children is that what I
put yeah yeah it is okay so today's
topic is can modern women be happy
without children and the reason that we
thought of this topic today is because
Jennifer Aniston at 53 did an interview
about IVF and fertility treatments in
the pursuit of motherhood she said that
treatments began several years ago in
her late 40s she didn't give a timeline
Jennifer Aniston said that she was
motivated by the success of her
contemporaries having children late like
Hilary Swank and Janet Jackson had kids
at 48 and 50 respectively Jennifer now
knows how much of an outlier these women
are now but didn't do the research when
she was younger Jennifer admitted that
she had all the money in the world but
was not able to get pregnant Jennifer
says she has no regrets and feels free
now about that the pressure of having
kids is off the table
so
question for the women
do you think that women can be happy
without children
but yeah I think I think they can be
happy I know lots of women that put
their career first nowadays and I think
a lot of people kind of underestimate
how much a child will change your life
because it's not something that goes
away like if you want to go out for
dinner or all the things you can do when
you're
by yourself without a child you can't do
them you always have to have child care
you know it costs a lot of money Child
Care is very expensive
um
and there's always stress there's always
the worry of is my child healthy is my
child safe and I think
that
when you don't have a child it seems
very attractive and in a lot of ways it
is if it's your dream to have a child
but you also like have to compromise a
lot of your own life so I feel like it
really depends on where you stand and
what your mindset is if you would like
to have a child obviously some people
since they're young they want to have a
child and you know they want they want
to be a stay-at-home wife and you know
they want the family life and stuff but
I feel like nowadays a lot of women are
also like you know what
to be honest I have so many dreams and
goals for myself and if a child would
come in the picture it's going to be
more difficult and I also don't want to
you know
be there less for my child because the
minute you put your career first for
example for myself if I'm a singer and
let's say I would go on a tour am I
gonna drop my child with a nanny 24 7.
because that child is not going to be
happy to see me 10 minutes a day reading
her a book or reading him a book like
that's not what parenting is so it's all
these factors come into play
um and I've been a nanny I've seen it I
used to Nanny for
um a billionaire family and the parents
literally sometimes would leave for like
four weeks and then the child is with a
nanny for 24 7 and the child calls the
nanny mummy so I feel like you know it's
it's very hard and I you know when
people say to me I don't want children I
think a lot of people judge them but
because I'm a nanny I've seen how much
of a pressure is people that shouldn't
have kids have kids exactly and then for
them for them a child is like a Prada
bag it's like sick I can put my um I can
put my money when I die I can give my
money to a child but at the end of the
day you've been with your child for like
10 that's it you know and then they drag
their children to like all these events
and they act like they're the great mom
and it's like babes if you weren't here
the whole day and they're like oh yeah
she's done this at school and then the
most funny thing is that my old Nanny
children would be like mum You're just
showing off you're never here and I
would be like
or they would be to people like do you
miss your mama they were like no all she
does is party and wear funky clothes I
was like Oh my days that kid is six so
it's like that's six yeah yeah wow so
and that's also a thing children are
highly intuitive like they know you know
that's why children you know when
children really gravitate towards like
certain people 100 and to some people
they don't it's because they feel safe
with certain people they talk things
yeah exactly so yeah I think I think you
can be happy but if it's really your
your dream to have a child and then it
all comes falling down because you can't
have children then it's a different
different convo I guess that's true
um when we go around I also want you
guys to say if you want kids yourself
um so do you want kids yeah yeah I do
you do okay and then you want to go next
so me I I have an eight-year-old I am a
mom okay but I make sure it's very sorry
I have an eight-year-old I am a mom so
but I'm not it wasn't planned I'm not
maternal in that way so I feel like if I
haven't if I didn't have him then like
now couldn't imagine anything different
but then every literally every person
that I said oh I'm having a baby and
they were like
just like it just wasn't it wasn't in
the plan but like I'm not
I make sure my time is very I treat my
job is a job I treat my socializing is
like I did like totally separate as in
like it's not I've never I've never took
anything away from him he has my full
attention at all times he's my priority
at all times so in that sense it's like
from a mum's point of view
like I would have been if you'd asked me
before I had him I'd have been like I
don't know if I'm ever gonna have kids
like it just wasn't in my plan but now
because he's there
like I would not imagine life without
like as my best friend would do oh like
I don't know the bond the bond is just
that like no one can describe it if
you're a mum you feel that but I also
have like best mates that
have said to me like I feel like I'm
just not gonna have kids and then it's
not like they say it as if they're not
going to be happy it's just like it's
just not in their Planet at that moment
but I feel like it's your situation it's
all to do with your relationship and
you're never gonna have a kid in like a
bad
when you're in a bad space unless it's
accidental obviously so I feel like if
you're planning to have kids and you
want to have that family life where
you're married your kids you settle down
and that's what that's like your dream
you cannot be happy without that because
that's your turn on Vision you want that
so that's what it is whereas some people
don't have that as their dream some
people want to be ambitious and like
build so much more in a career sense
then so it's like what's your priorities
do you want the family life do you want
this life or do you want an in-between
are you ever going to be happy with
either do you feel like you would have
been equally happy if you didn't have a
child
um it's all I don't know that's an odd
question because like I was happy but I
was very young I added my 21. so it's
like 21 what like what what is do I have
really yeah you know what I mean I
didn't know life as I do now whereas I
feel like if I saw myself at 21 I would
have said no I'm not having kids yet
blah blah blah but me at 29 like and
then if if you ask me that and I'll be
like I'm not gonna where I was like turn
it up like I don't know what I would
have I I still live my life we're going
like we do things a lot together like I
don't see I don't see why yes do not be
there for me to not have fun like we go
on dates together every Sunday would do
a day it's like that's my life partner
at the moment it just does
um in my situation I'm single so no okay
like but it wouldn't not to say that
word for the record would you have more
kids okay yeah okay what about you do
you want kids so I always wanted to be a
young mom
um and then I turned 30 this year and I
actually had like a midlife crisis
because I was like I have no kids I have
no relationship like my career is good
but I want that like old school family
like that love that life and I did get
sad thinking like
I'm not gonna just settle and like have
someone's kid just for the sake of
having a kid like I want the the whole
package
so if I can't have that like am I ever
gonna have kids and I did actually have
a conversation with my mum the other day
and I was like do I need to freeze my ex
and it was like a serious thing because
I was like what if I meet someone in a
couple of years and you know like your
body
you don't know what's going to happen to
it as a woman so it's quite as scary
thing if it's something that you want
mm-hmm
okay what do you think
um I from a personal perspective
do I want kids first of all yes I do one
children of my own
um I think obviously like some of the
ladies have said
um Society pressures women to kind of
think that that's sort of the role to go
down road to go down to have children
have a family be a wife potentially
um and I think especially where you
reach a certain well women anyway are on
a biological clock whether we like it or
not we are and I think that keeps us
some of us up at night knowing that so
um
having
the thought of having children for most
women is obviously a priority for most
of us but obviously with that most women
would lack a relationship a foundation a
family
I think in today's society looking at a
lot of the relationships especially the
ones that I put on platforms and social
media a lot of them seem to be failing
and collapsing so I think no shame but
it's it's real talk so I think
in one hand you want yes yeah you do
want children but at the same time you
don't want to just settle down with
anybody and end up in a worse situation
there are plenty of women out there that
are single moms and are doing a great
job but still have always said they
would have preferred to have done this
with a partner
um so I think it's down to the
individual finding their happiness I
think
like some people feel already it depends
on who you are what you call and classes
happiness because some people's
happiness are traveling exploring
um and some people just free-spirited
and they're interested in other things
other people I have that tunnel vision
of wanting kids in their family so
to answer the question in terms of
happiness it comes it will be obviously
down to the person but I definitely
think that
women should
be selfish in their decisions
so that they're not in predicaments and
allow themselves to be pressured by by
not even just by Society by immediate
people like family and friends how do
you know it's society and not biology uh
you know like we've done some in a
certain way for thousands of years I
think it's a bit of both I think because
we all know that but we're in a
biological clock
we have like we're all thinking the same
thing but also I think
I don't know obviously we have things
like social media where you see people
uploading at certain age that they're
married I've got lots of friends of mine
that have that are engaged or about to
walk down the aisle at the moment and
where you've been socialized to
go to school at a certain age with your
age mates then you go to college at a
certain age with your age mates then you
graduate you get a job
you've been conditioned that at a
certain age you do the same thing as
your age mates when you get to a certain
age and people around you are doing
certain things like getting proposed to
and you're not it kind of does make you
feel a type of way from being completely
real so did that answer your question
okay
um that's fine um I'm not gonna lie I do
oh sorry is that better
I'm not gonna lie I don't want children
and I think when I was younger I used to
how old are you I'm 23. and you don't
want kids around I'm turning 24 next
month yeah I'm 24 and you don't want
kids around I I used to when I was
younger I was like oh maybe if I was
younger you're only 24.
when I was like 19 18 21 whatever I used
to think that maybe um if I met somebody
that really wasn't children I might
change my mind and I might be like you
know what maybe one kid but as I'm
getting the older I'm getting the more I
hear about Festival pregnancy secondly
raising the child second like it takes
up so much of your life and maybe I'm
selfish maybe I'm not I don't know but
at this point in my life I think to
myself I'm like do I genuinely want to
raise a kid no okay I don't I like
children as well that's the funny part I
love children if my friends had kids
imma be the [ __ ] Auntie that's
[ __ ] so I mean I'm gonna spend money
on you but to have my own child I'm
bringing and 24 7 I'm not doing the
sleepless nights how would you think
about being like 55 and childless
as long as me and my babies are
traveling having a good time I'm not
going to have children okay I'm not
gonna lie okay
um and then what about you I think it
depends on what type of person you are
so if one of them people depends on
other people to be happy like you rely
on other people's happiness for your
happiness You're Gonna Want Kids to make
you happy like I've got friends who have
got black kids that shine and stuff like
that and I've got friends who can't have
kids but all they want is a kid but I
know if they have that kid it's going to
make them happy so I think it depends on
your own person or who you are whether
you want kids on our own whether it
depends if what brings you happiness
really I think so some people's
happiness as kids some people's it's not
some people's traveling do you know what
I mean so to me it don't really matter
I want kids I want two kids and I'm done
okay guys I'm just show of hands how
many of you want to be married
um if he comes through with the ring
because yeah all right okay um you two
do you do you want to be married you
don't no okay so three out of four would
you guys um would you want a long-term
partner like yeah yeah like if you'd be
with a girl for 20 years would you do
that yeah okay okay so would you guys
see the point of being or getting
married or being with a long-term
partner if you didn't get kids out of it
see that's the thing like for a lot of
women some women might say they don't
want kids but
if if you are saying that because the
majority of men want kids so if you're
saying that then it might be a
possibility that you may be alone
because the person that you get with the
most likely going to want kids so I
think yeah
[Music]
yeah I would find it hard to like
take it seriously like because I know
deep down for me
like it's true like I gotta be real like
I couldn't really look at the
relationship as a serious one
if I'm not really at some point going to
Bear children and it like for me as a
man like I know
like I want to leave a legacy I need my
family to grow I need my name to carry
on that's always been a big thing for me
and my family so that's a man thing as
well like oh man we want to leave a
legacy yeah like we don't want to just
be on here well if you're not the
problem and you're not other ones who
can't have kids why are you shooting
blanks
yeah
you ain't blaming me because you don't
want you minority though not majority a
majority of men can have kids
what do you think is going to be the
problem the people that have been on
birth control for 10 years
not every girl is these days and age
because it weighed us to you yeah but
then they have how many abortions that's
up to them that is up to them so a lot
though it's a lot of girls
to be fair is it
from what I hear from you
speak from experience do you think that
abortions like reduce the chance of you
having children in the future
in some cases does it depend on the type
of abortion or just abortions I think in
general some people I mean I don't know
that I'm not going to pretend to be like
a science like Superman
like this is okay okay when I was a kid
when I was a kid I everyone was getting
on birth control right and logically I
was thinking I just feel like if you
stop your fertility that's bad
so I'm not like I know I was never
really like I was on it a little bit but
never really and I remember all my
friends were talking to me like when I
said this to them at like 16 17 whatever
they all were looking at me like I was
nuts and then 10 years later that we it
[ __ ] with your hormones it does all
this stuff so I just think logically
like to be honest I don't know if you're
if you're taking something that like
kills the child that's growing and yeah
I just can't imagine that's great I I
have mixed feelings about that because
there's so many types of contraception
in general and birth control that is in
the pill every day is honestly very
chaotic in terms of how good it is for
you in terms of your fertility in the
future but I feel like it's there's so
many like advances in science in general
that we don't know how it's gonna like
the repercussions in general how it's
going to affect you so I feel like it's
not quite it's it's only experiment you
know what I mean and if taking birth
control is better for you and you know
what I'm actually pissed off about the
fact that there's so many like we should
we could spend so much time and so much
energy and so much money on birth
control in terms of adjusting men but we
don't in terms of what do you mean
adjusting men as in them being
responsible no no I mean not just
we have birth control that stops us from
releasing eggs or we have birth controls
that pauses the period or whatever but
we don't have birth yeah but the
emphasis is on the women why because
they're the one that's going to be
carrying the child so so that means you
because if anything obviously the guy
can can leave you can I might have to
pay some money what I'm saying oh
because nine months of pregnancy yeah
that's what I'm I'm not talking about
pregnancy I'm talking about the con like
conception yeah but you're taking it to
stop pregnancy yeah but the men can also
stop because
we have all the power like I'm sorry we
have every Power when it comes to not
having a child yeah 41 forms of birth
control yeah that's true that's on TV
abortion that's what I'm saying here
there's so many forms of birth control
for the woman yeah but there's so few
for men why there must be a reason
scientifically I'm sure there is but I
just don't know what it is I'm just
country live streaming I think it has to
do with with that we carried a child
yeah because at the end of the day he's
right if they leave I'm stuck with a big
belly for nine months going through
every trimester like it's not fair but
life isn't fair but at the end of the
day like they're not gonna carry the
baby in their belly so I feel like
logically when they started doing birth
control control they were like okay
who's the first person that is
yeah but I think she's trying to say
it's not just necessarily like people go
on it because they like their periods
are so bad yeah that it kind of like
balances or they have like too much
estrogen or something like that I don't
know I'm not on it for that reason but
is there anything is that is there
anything that would make you want to
have kids or would you like if you met
someone would you say it with chess and
say I don't want kids I've said it
before and it's quite funny actually
because you mentioned that the fact that
um a lot of women would like end up
alone if they told someone that they
were not they didn't want children in
general I don't true because I have told
people like if you ask me oh do you
really want because I'm like no not
really because every man on here want
kids yeah majority the majority in a
very very small Stone size like let's
think about you just said a small sample
size because you said the guy that I'm
curious
guys I'm curious guys off camera does
anyone not want children from the men
anyone
okay
I'm just curious does anyone not like do
doesn't want kids is anyone saying yes
majority no I don't think maybe I'm in
the morning and that's completely fine
I'm probably just trying to sleep with
these yeah
it is what it is that's completely fine
but like I just I don't know
um I feel like a lot of people have
children because they feel like they're
supposed to rather than because they
genuinely want how old did you say you
were again I'm 23. so see one thing you
did say is that when you was 19 you you
was all over having kids no I didn't
that's not what I said I said I was more
likely to be persuaded into having one
child but as I've gotten older The more
I've learned the less I want children
okay the kids for life so you've got to
understand the one exactly like even
when you're a 56 year old that is your
baby that's my life as soon as you have
a child spend your entire life goes to
the child whether you want to or not and
the thing is if I had a child 100 I'll
be [ __ ] diverted to my baby but do I
want to be complete it's just it's just
interesting because is like when people
list the reasons that they don't want to
have children you kind of admitted this
early on like it's why they say modern
women are selfish because everything's
about me me it's like I don't want to
give up my free time I don't want to
give up my job I don't want to give up
my mind
but there's a problem being selfish if
you're not selfish and you and you used
to be naive and blindfolded and act like
you can do everything and you do a
half-hearted job
I I agree like I agree with what you
were saying about the nannies like I'm
not saying every single person should
have kids but usually the people that
don't have kids I would say are selfish
nah you have to be selfish you have to
be simple I genuinely disagree with that
I'm sorry that's really crazy being
selfish for a woman has a shelf life to
be honest in what way in a sense where
like you can be selfish up to a point
but then you kind of gotta make a
decision in it like yeah yeah
but I couldn't have a kid with my life
right now I think which is
understandable but that doesn't mean
like you still don't have a shelf life
on being selfish yeah I don't know I
need you to elaborate on shelf life and
being selfish okay as you as you said
earlier um like obviously there's a
certain time limit on obviously when a
woman can well possibly not sorry
yourself then maybe at a certain time
limit on having a child so obviously you
can be selfish up to a point but then
sooner or later you've got to kind of
make the decision whether you obviously
want a child or you don't so that's I
agree you know what yeah
I think if if you've known from young
that I genuinely want children 100
if you want children to [ __ ] have
your babies like I don't mind that
actually I mean like if you want your
baby if you want 10 kids have 10 kids I
don't mind that at all in fact I want my
friends to have kids so I can be an
auntie you know I mean you're scared I
don't want to be pregnant
of course I'm scared because you're
scared of no it's not because I'm scared
but also the responsibility that comes
with a child is so much for me I'm
barely functioning as a human being I do
not want to take care of another human
being as well and I'm not telling you
that's fine I'm all about people doing
what they want to do I don't even think
that every single girl should have it
there's a lot of people that shouldn't
have kids no but I think the people that
shouldn't have kids are usually too
selfish to have children like just like
you know what some sort of scary thought
because you were talking about age
earlier yeah and you were saying what if
you're 55 and I'm thinking yeah I want
children but let's say I wouldn't want
children yet and at 55 I'm home with 80
cats because no one I'm sorry but it can
happen you know and then I'm like it
would have been nice to have someone
that and and at 55 you kind of switch to
like the men's perspective because
because yeah because you know they start
to treat you like they treat the men
because people aren't attracted to you
as much anymore I just want to take it
back to this point that you made about
if you don't want kids you're selfish I
actually genuinely disagree with that
because to me especially the points that
you guys have made for wanting kids is
like I want to carry on my legacy my
legacy you're talking about yourself
that's inherently selfish
why does it matter now women don't care
about their legs
well why would it matter what Legacy
matters to you within 100 years manager
you're gonna be forgotten regardless
yeah but that's what my child is for
yeah but but two generations down and
they're gonna keep having kids but
they're not gonna remember
you personally but I've heard stories
about my great grandpa
a lot of people know a lot of people if
they if they descended from someone that
was like great lately they always make
fun of me in the comments
but seriously like like people know that
they descended from him and he was alive
how long ago that's really cool yeah but
like you're dead
everyone knows your name and what you
did
not meet you or they may have met you
but I'm sorry I mean I just think the
point is that something like bigger than
yourself like I'm just thinking if I'm
if I'm 65 and by myself like one who's
gonna take care of you because someone's
got to take care of you and older but
you don't have any other friend and the
second and and the second part is like
like you want to die alone but even even
even even better even by that logic
though what's the purpose of us doing
anything yeah
we're just gonna die cool
do you want to settle down settle down
with a partner yeah yeah of course I do
just be able like that's the signal
that's because wherever you settle down
with most likely the may not but most
likely they're gonna want kids I'm sorry
are you is it ten that's what whatever
okay
it makes a difference it's not a man
then obviously I understand that that's
why I make it a good point to be like
hey if they bring up anything to do with
children or if the conversation comes up
I'm gonna be straight up I feel like I'm
not gonna lie I'm not really interested
if you're trying to I don't like legit
I'm gonna get into that yeah
say it straight away I find it no no I
find it interesting to hear like what
people say or why they think the way
they think because I'm like okay I might
disagree but okay you might have points
at what point I was making is that I
mean I'm sure you as a mother could say
like that you have to put the kid before
you exactly the situation like my kid
comes first in every situation I'm not
like like I said I want maternal and
before no I shocked my mum on my child's
birthday every year goes well done
and all my friends and my family that
never expected it from me but I am like
self-proclaimed no I am I think I'm a
good mom definitely no one said any
difference to me but um like but I just
never expected a one in the plan but
like it is my priority in every
situation in my life and it just changed
your life so much but if if you don't
want kids then that's fine I feel like
everyone's got different it's like
saying what do you want to do for a
living what is what's your career choice
what's your job if that's your dream
that everyone's just totally different
but girls feel the pressure and with the
thing where it was like something to do
with having kids and blah blah blah what
is what I was going to say before is for
men it is a legacy because what do you
do when you get married you take the
man's name then what do you do when you
have kids it takes the man's name it's
carrying on their name and they're like
they're honor and their dads and their
dads before them because you all take
their name and you pass it down and
that's what it is like we've just been
that's
that's what it is for most people if
they don't see the dads a lot of people
[Music]
we're going to the birth certificate
I'll let you go and then you go
generally like like for me I think it's
cool to have a legacy like yeah if I get
married and have a kid obviously it
won't have my last name but then that's
going to be my last name do you know
what I mean so that's my legacy
regardless I think that's cool what were
you gonna say I just take the
conversation back you just this is for
you
um if you were ever on a date with a
girl that you really really were into
really liked her she ticked all your
boxes but she had a deal breaker and
well she said she don't want kids you
don't want kids would you wait wait no
no you're saying especially but I'm just
asking you would you look to persuade
her would you try do you think there's
room for that do you think that support
there's a possibility would I try to
sway a woman or like influence her too
or would you try to try to if you would
like to if a woman saying to me that she
doesn't want kids I'm not going to try
and convince her but listen recreational
might be an option
because obviously unless you say you
know what as I said when the food comes
down say because that year is a very big
thing especially funny to me that men
talk about having children it's so jokes
why is it jokes because you man don't do
any of the work required talk about how
do you talk about protecting
and providing my ass
physical hard work required to carry a
child what's what's harder giving birth
or raising a child raising it's both of
them
I'm sorry a challenge for life
I'm not trying to be rude but like dogs
give birth
acting like this is so crazy look every
other species I'm not talking about the
given birth part okay
because fair enough here you are right
we don't do the physical part but
there's other things that we have to
deal with
it's hard be dealing with a woman that's
carrying a whole human being in her
stomach
I have a friend right now shout out Ali
love you but like
I think more afterwards mentally
emotionally and mentally afterwards is
that that's the test that is a big test
no matter how how about sorry pregnant
people no matter how bad you feel right
now it will get worse
I love you but it's bad
you just your emotions are everywhere
your head's everywhere and nothing makes
sense it's um it's a roller coaster I
get I get what you're saying like
obviously physically we're not pushing
out the baby but like what would you
actually want the man to do like what
can we do I'm not I'm not saying
thought that you don't carry your baby
can you clarify what you meant no I just
meant that you guys are like oh yeah of
course that I would want to have
children or whatever whatever but it's
like I don't know I do to the night
feeds so you change nappies are you
there 24 7. if I need a break
I'm talking about night faces physical
it is physical she's complicated
a lot of the guys do it a lot of yeah
there's a lot of guys that do it but
there's a [ __ ] lot at that door yeah
but this is this is why you choose
exactly when you get a chance 100 you
know how many people I've seen here they
have relationship issues and then they
think you know
baby and this baby yeah is is gonna get
born into this toxic relationship it's
gonna be the leverage it's gonna be like
but you acted up I'm taking the child
really minimizing the guy's role though
like like men have to go to work every
day and provide for you like that what
do you why are you acting like that's
nothing they have to protect you someone
breaks into your house like they're the
ones that are in charge they're the ones
that have to protect you you're not
gonna go downstairs
I think she's talking about the people
that don't what are you talking about so
for me lightweight you said the the
protector and the reason I've always
been that person
what you said where you're all like you
you would choose someone that is gonna
give you all the things I got promising
things it didn't happen if you had a
choice
I've done everything wait so but that's
just three months not in general but
were you married before you had the time
so yeah
guys guys you guys okay guys it needs to
be you okay one at a time one at a time
one okay go ahead yeah no I'm not
complaining in any way and I'm the first
person to listen it was not fandom blah
blah blah but like because I went
through with that situation right but
you're saying like men men
why would you not choose someone that's
gonna give you these things I got told I
wasn't gonna get them things but I
expected those things right I just
didn't get there right but I'm saying it
but for me I just rolled with it and
then I I'm not complaining which is fine
I shouldn't expect it right do you think
like it probably would have been avoided
if you got married first because
it depends on the person no difference
to my situation except from a [ __ ]
message actions though it would prove
more than just him saying
she needed a ring just to confirm that
he wouldn't be a man of his word is that
what we're saying it's not just a ring I
mean I'm just being stupid
do you know how big of a risk marriage
is for men in 2022 okay
wait wait guys do you know how big of a
risk of marriage is for men in 2022 okay
we we leave 70 to 80 of the time 90 of
their college educated they can lose up
to 75 percent and take the kids okay and
give okay we're talking about a man that
didn't keep his word we're not talking
about whether sorry
the point that she's making is that um
what you should have waited until
marriage yeah to say that he would
promise those things
because because because and I'm not like
it's your situation I don't know yet but
but the point is like if somebody does
something it's better than them saying
that they're going to do something like
I can say I can say I'm a millionaire
that doesn't make me more
like what you've said that you like all
right so if you'd have got married would
it be different no like for my situation
personally the reason like it would not
have made a difference if we were
married or not if if anything it would
have just made a hundred people there
was nothing I was what
I have a question going back to um you
said you protect and provide do you not
think it would be better if your son had
a father in his life or daughter
I would love so much for him to the
Father Figure like I've I'm lucky enough
to have men and family members that are
male in my life to be able to show them
that kind of way but sometimes I do
think I wish like every day I wish I
wish I had someone there yeah that
showed him that side of it but I'm quite
masculine in that kind of energy like
when it comes to projected or whatever I
will I'll I'll do more Manda but I know
what you mean that that it I don't know
I say because it's weird we're best for
Mars mom's like Oh you followed no not
me get up just on yours I'm quite I kind
of try and make it balanced to do before
um but I do wish it did ever
a better was there red flags because a
lot of women say this year but I
guarantee there was some kind of signs
that he was that guy that doesn't keep
his promises there was always red flags
but like so that it wasn't planned I
would not plan to have a child at that
point now talking about the commitment
in general I'm talking about like the
commitment side and the keeping his word
side I guarantee there was red flags
that was the question in hand like would
you would would you not want to get
married first I would have gained
nothing from a marriage but do you think
it would have been different if it was I
I also it's to the guys as well do you
think it changes if a child comes
unplanned the way you look at having a
child yeah because to me yeah I would
have had one if not yeah yeah because I
feel like that changes the question as
well because I feel like if you know you
want to have a kid then you can mentally
prepare okay sick I'm gonna yeah I'm
gonna provide if this comes unplanned
yet if I was a man not to say that I
would run out and be like see you later
[ __ ] but um but I do think that
let's say yeah we we have been seeing
each other for like a year or something
she becomes pregnant
um there for example I don't want to I
don't want to have a kid now she wants
to have the kid I'll I'll help her
because I don't want to leave and be the
[ __ ] that's like by
um but then when it comes to you know
you're eight months in and this child is
gonna come in like a month I would be
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants yeah because
it changes the combo you know because
you can't mentally prepare and you I
still don't say that they should leave
never but I do think it really depends
on was this baby planned because that
changes because
I mean the idea is like we're 100 in
control of birth yeah so whether you had
it or not it wasn't yeah I we had the
conversation I said right these are the
options
are we making a go of it like what's
happening we had the full conversation
we had full 50 50 import and we're like
if you want me to get I will do you know
what I mean and then we had the import
and then it would we came to the
conclusion and we will try our best to
make a family for this channel yeah and
it did not work and you said there were
red flags before yeah
I'm not trying to like come at you like
no no I'm just I'm just saying like a
lot of times like as women yeah we'll
kind of make it seem like we're a victim
in the situation
right right but I'm saying I'm just
saying I'm saying in general yeah but
like like there are red flags that
happen before and we we choose to move
forward yeah so it's not like a gotcha
like he got you it's like okay
we're kind of evading the the whole
argument like so look I think we're
gonna put some wholeness on them in as
well there's two types of man there's
one that lives up to his word and
there's one that doesn't it's simple as
that yeah but I think you could um
what's your name sorry in the green and
Angie Angie I think you could learn
something from this so basically I think
what a lot of people but especially
women are missing is the ability to sow
seeds right they don't sell seeds they
don't think long term they just think
like oh yeah and now I feel so this I
feel so dark but you were saying that at
19 yeah I wanted one kid now it's I
don't want nothing your brain's not
fully developed
it's gonna sound rude you know it's
gonna sound rude but like there's some
studies that say till 25 your brain is
still developing so there's some shots
you're just gonna have to take I was
gonna is this a battlefield hold on let
me just finish if it's a battlefield and
you know people are running at you
there's some shots you're gonna have to
take you haven't got 100 accuracy all
right no that's true it's true you're
gonna have to start just licking off
licking it off because when you get to
55 like four years ago you was thinking
one now it's zero but it is I need a
half
so sometimes you need to think about
sowing seeds and don't and be
open-minded I think a lot of young
people sorry to like you're not trying
to play it down I'm 26 but I'm awesome
[Laughter]
one of you in this room proves me wrong
or makes me think differently I'm going
to allow myself to think and listen but
a lot of people are too hard-headed
about something and that's why at 55
they're regret now oh okay
I wanted to add to what you just said
though because the the obviously I feel
like a lot of women I'm not a woman but
I feel like a lot evidently well I feel
like a lot of women will get to a
certain like there will be a switch at
some point like you'll be playing with
your your friend's kid or you'll see a
kid a cute baby on on Instagram or
something like that and then you're like
when you get past that when you get past
35 those come in it's it's it's you you
don't have a choice anymore or like as
the older you get the choices goals but
it depends on your situation I have a
couple stats for you guys
um
what do you guys think the average age
is of first child like to give birth in
the West in England
under the age of 25. first kid as you
think okay
um between 20 um 25 to 27.
thanks okay
um 28 to 30.
or above maybe uh 30 to 35. okay okay
it's it's 30. that's the um
in 2022 the average age for a woman to
give birth is 30. and it's growing up um
and at 30
um 90 of your eggs are gone wow
the rate of women giving birth in their
20s has decreased while giving birth in
their 30s and 40s has exploded
only 11 of women that freeze their eggs
end up with a live birth at the end of
the process yeah that's good and how
much how much does freezing eggs cost
around a round of Ivy a round of IVF
costs around 12
000 on average in the United States the
price the price of an IVF at the private
the price of a round of IVF in the UK at
a private clinic clinic is about five
thousand pounds
and that's a lot less than the US okay
okay everyone needs to get me pregnant
guys guys so I'm just curious have you
ever considered the risks of geriatric
pregnancy and did you know those stats
so raise your hand if you knew those
stats well is that geriatric pregnancy
um is pregnancy after 35. yeah and my
maid's mom had it at four and she's six
inches perfectly fine
exception
all right so my my parents also have
given birth like my parents and their
grandparents have given birth lately my
both of my grandparents no I I
understand but I wouldn't bet on it why
would I bet on that that's stupid yeah
maybe it wasn't your time to have kids
yet some people not read to have kids
till they later how is it it's your
choice exactly
right and I'm saying that's fine but
don't complain about the results
you don't know what they do like
Jennifer Aniston Jennifer Aniston is
that's what she she is not just one
person and that's what I'm saying no
girls do it all the time
how many girls you see crying on Tick
Tock everyone every girl here you guys
are all pretty enough that you know
someone in your friend zone that's ready
to marry you tomorrow
I don't think that's true though because
I want kids I want them now but I just
I'm not gonna just have a kid for this
so I think it's unfair to say that it's
my choice it's not my choice because
yeah I could have a kid with you if I
wanted to sorry to pick you up
but you know I need to be in love with
you you know I want the whole the whole
package I don't want just a sperm donor
because if that's the case I'll go to a
bank
okay but it's a choice because there are
mat I'm sure you have men that want to
date you right I'm sure you I mean I'm
sure you have them I'm sure you have men
that you know are good guys in your
friend zone that you know I don't want
to [ __ ] them and I understand but then
it's like it's it's basically like the
men you don't want don't want you yep no
and it's it's everyone everyone that's
single if the man if the man you wanted
wanted you you would be in a
relationship with them not necessarily
it's like it's like women we don't none
of us like we don't set how do you know
that it is it's the memo like maybe I
just don't want anyone maybe no one's
like living up to the plate okay
okay well I just think that this there's
one of you and there's the whole
population of men
so I
know what I'm sorry to say but the UK
mid
I think people nowadays they meet
someone and then they you know he can be
um if you're into men like he can be you
know the whole package but because of
Socials you're like oh but he's but he's
but he's but so I feel like a lot of
people struggle to actually like build
something with someone because they're
always thinking there might be something
better out there
no it's because like we're all chasing
after the same men women only sweat
bread and dating apps five percent of
the time
we all need we only that's the number
one way people are meeting dating apps
nowadays we only swipe right which one
so I'm gonna download them
it's true it's true it was we only swipe
right five percent of the time most
women rate 80 percent of men is
unattractive not just okay
I've had the I've had hinge before and I
think I've one match
yeah and so
to me it's treacherous out there but
that's the whole population of men so it
it says if you're single over a certain
age you're probably too picky yeah
I mean it's like but that's a choice
it's a choice to be picky yeah yeah
but see okay what percent of men do you
think are six foot then I mean I've seen
this foreign
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
than get a guy on their level die alone
again your level is what you can get to
commit to you that's your level
that's your level that's your level if
you say my ex-boyfriend was ugly or
medium ugly no no no you still chose him
yeah I've definitely dimmed my light a
couple of times and it still ended the
same that's true
what do you mean dim to your life I've
dated a little bit they're out like I'm
well out their league
no your league is what you did
no no no no no no no no no no no no
you give them the Uglies
we are talking over each other as one
conversation thank you sometimes they
have a little one-two joke and they're
funny and you fall for it and you're
like oh you know what okay so I'll give
you a chance if he's funny that puts him
in the top percentage of guys at
something like the whole point if if you
date him that's the best option you had
at the time you wouldn't you wouldn't
date someone to think you're trying to
sometimes you just don't want to do
something
different you're trying to make
something different you're tired and
then the normal the worst because
sometimes I bugged the world to me I
have enough let me start acting up now
because look at my babes now look she's
at my league
okay but you guys like I'm just being
out y'all sound delusional as hell
no
yeah
it's not delusional your exes are your
level my answers are my levels
that's like wait wait that's like me
saying I'm a millionaire but I don't
have the proof no I don't I have the
proof no I don't know
the only thing the only thing that
counts is a ring so if you don't ever
like it doesn't count maybe maybe I'll
give you like a 10-year relationship or
something like yeah you know I'll give
you maybe I do think once I do think if
you think you're above someone League
wise you still chose that yourself yeah
you've not chose that like because you
think
um that's that's not your day in your
lane basically you've done you've done
that for a reason why because you've
done that because the ones you normally
go for it's not working people in your
league are not working
here okay
this is what happens this is what
happens a girl that's a six will date an
eight and he doesn't treat her well
because [ __ ] you're shooting out of your
league if that's out of your feet
stop stop stop stop stop
eight State six is all the goddamn no I
don't know
guys guys
they're gonna choose a six over me okay
guys guys in eight eight sixes all the
time men swipe right on data I can pull
the data for you Men's Wear Brandon
dating apps 45 of the time
all the women saying yeah that they're
dating below why are the men that you
want not committing to
so now you want someone who's below me
who can be like yes babe no babe yes
babe yes babe
yes babe what is this league this league
sounds like it's all old
if you do that one more time we're gonna
sub you out you cannot be over talking
the host you cannot you cannot be over
talking people here
um can I say something I feel like when
we talk about this thing yeah
I feel like a lot of girls nothing
against no one
when I hear you talk about League I feel
like it's all based on looks but for me
personally yeah I'd rather date a guy
that's maybe less attractive but he's
super sweet you know he has his morals
in place he has goals for himself he
he's good for his family like I'd rather
have that than a 10 that has six women
on the side or whatever he's doing
that's right
wait wait go I agree with saying which
is why I disagree with what you're
saying about my exes they have to have
been in my league because the person
they tried to make out they were because
the reason why they're not in my league
isn't just because their their looks
it's based on things like morals and the
person they painted themselves out to be
was a man of their word and I got to
know them and I realized they want a man
of the world I didn't realize you're not
in my league so therefore what you said
is Cap because it meant I've met they
made them themselves out like yeah if
your league is what you can get to
commit to you if the man that you can
get to commit to you you feel like are
below your league you're delusional yeah
the man the man just because you sleep
up doesn't mean they'll commit to you um
it's delusional it's not because
everyone's different everyone's
different you don't know everyone's
situation so I was actually engaged
about to get married and I called it off
so I wasn't delusional so I was with
someone for six years about to get
married wedding period yeah that's your
level because there's no humidity yeah
yeah
yeah I get that what you mean Commission
because he's the one who obviously
proposed the men proposal because
they're committed yeah I've had people
want to do it and I'm like no because
you're not my guy you're not and if he
committed to you that's your life
cause I'm saying no because you're not
that guy I'm still waiting for an answer
why these men that you're supposedly on
the level that you're on are not
committing I didn't see it I was on a
level I'm saying you've got to date
within your lane no you said you did you
said you delayed you you dated below no
I didn't say I did I said people date
below just because they want to try
something different all right so why did
the people that are dating below why why
can't they let them in on their level
because the ones they're trying to on
their level with is not working for them
so you think so you are telling me every
single girl you've did it has always
been the same no but I'm not saying I'm
just going off what you said no and I'm
telling you what I've said something
okay I have a question I have a question
okay what how would you know what your
level is if it's if it's not the guy
committing to you because if it's not
the guy committing to you
what would you go off of what else would
you go off of the guys you're sleeping I
gotta like your pictures on Instagram
somebody who is Emily personally would
be someone that even if things didn't
work out because of chemistry because of
maybe small things that we're not into I
can still look at and say you know I
respect him yeah Eve and he has the same
mutual respect for me
I have a question did he commit yes okay
so again it goes back to your level is
what you can get to commit to you but
you said that men that are that are 10
sometimes or eight sometimes date sixes
so that means the six is not how can
that work if it's going back
women are hypergamous women date up
women
okay through opposite opposite I'm
pretty sure men date up women date Dad
okay I have a question just raise your
hands um do you guys want someone that
makes more or less money than you I'm
not bothered no I'm too okay okay okay
okay if you had to pick more or less
like raise your hand raise your hand if
it's more sugar daddy raise your hand if
it's more raise your hand if you prefer
someone that makes loss prefer okay okay
[Laughter]
I'm asking you a question do you want
someone that dates makes more or less
you don't get to pick the questions
what would your preference be I didn't
say you wouldn't go down okay I'm saying
what would your preference would you
want do you guys want someone taller or
shorter tala do you want someone
stronger than you or skinnier than you
oh I like a skinny man
okay okay okay okay okay hands up hands
up if you prefer guys skinnier than you
you prefer I used to no no no hands up
hands up I'm on the fence okay okay
hands up if you prefer guys must more
muscular than you
it depends on how okay okay
this is this is the point this is the
point we date up when I'm talking about
when I'm talking about specifically
dating up I'm talking about looks
specifically only men like let's look at
like just let's base it on celebrities
for example celebrity men correct
celebrities are the like that that's
Hollywood okay but let's let's look at
the everyday thing okay okay wait wait
do you like let's let's stop stop
interrupting me okay let's look at the
everyday person the everyday person on a
dating app men swipe right 45 of the
time women swipe right five percent of
the time dating apps we would agree is
mostly about looks right mostly look so
who is the pickier sex the women okay
can I say something though
um just like from perspective at the
minute I go to a lot of events okay
every event I go to
probably 90 of the women are beautiful
pretty they've got something big bum
nice lips the percentage of men
that are attractive at these events
compared to the percentage of women
there might be like a couple of guys in
there that oh you're sweet okay I'm just
I'm just I just want to do an experiment
here you know just an experiment I want
everyone to rate themselves one to ten
honestly
to be fair to be fair I'm gonna start I
give myself a five go ahead wow go ahead
I think it's time for subscribe
I would say like a seven seven okay I
would say good like a good eight eight
okay yeah I'd say that in eight so I'll
put some weight on eight okay ten ten
okay yeah oh sorry go ahead and mend two
men two oh uh nine with a trim nine with
it seven seven without a trim okay seven
point five seven point five
is that what five and a half five and a
half six okay humble seven okay strong
eight with a trim okay okay so all right
all right all right all right all right
outside of me everyone here rated
themselves that's a girl above average
um
yes so what's the average oh no
I think you understood the question yeah
right okay yeah yeah okay oh I don't
know I just feel like everyone's got
preferences okay no it's awkward okay
it depends what day it is today okay
[Laughter]
I need some volume
I'll go down lower second personality
makes it better okay seven you said
seven okay go ahead I'm sticking with
them okay okay yeah
okay did anyone switch it why do we go
through this again
I'm gonna bring it down to the six I
think a six okay okay you're pretty
sorry
she's not gonna have no baggage either
but my point is outside of Me no one
rated themselves as average from the
women and most people are not an average
girl so what's average then I'm not an
average babe I think most people are no
no one thinks they're average
I mean I what anything average that's
absolutely fine but I know but the point
is like women tend to overrate
themselves yeah generally I feel like
the Girls Ain't Got Confidence it it
makes a lot of issues within the scent
and the relationships
you suffer in life if you do not think
how do you suffer yourself
it's from sucks from succeeding in
school as a child to like jobs to like
doing anything different you know you
need to rate yourself you need to know
to come on this platform and hold that
mic in front of them yourself you have
to have a level of confidence you've got
to look in your mirror and believe in
yourself how can you not I'm being
really okay okay okay I I agree with you
I think confidence is important if if
you have
like the stuff to back it up so so if
you're gonna come on a podcast and you
can't talk it doesn't matter how
confident you are you still can't talk
if you're gonna rate yourself a 10 and
you're not a 10 like it doesn't make you
a 10. and that's fine and that's why I
said that's fine if you think you're
average because there's some people that
are average but you see me
because obviously you know me personally
but I'm just saying that in a room for
the people that I'm not that don't know
me I'm not gonna water down how I feel
when I'm by myself let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question I do
agree that there's some people let me
let me okay let me ask you a question
what celebrity do you think is a 10.
I'll be honest with you give me give me
one please please don't make this
complicated I'm not gonna make it
complicated but I'm not gonna lie to you
okay I know you answer the questions and
I'm here to answer but I can't I'm not a
celebrity I'm not a fan of somebody
okay you know let me ask someone else
yeah can someone raise your hand if you
can give me give me okay Rihanna Rihanna
do you feel like you're as pretty as
Rihanna do I think that's pretty yeah
um I wouldn't compare myself to Rihanna
um because I just wouldn't I don't look
at other girls and compare myself okay
that's what that's just something I
don't do I find it really strange we're
talking very very like vapid very very
like looks based only yeah yeah it looks
like if you're gonna be [ __ ] like
yeah why wouldn't you compare yourself
to Rihanna
I don't do that I'm not Rihanna I'm on
the base of this conversation
if I had to compare myself to Rihanna if
you look force me to look at reality
I say who's prettier I wouldn't say
she's prettier than me and I'm being
honest that's worse
I'm not even saying that just to be
difficult like I I don't want to be
difficult I mean it's just something for
my truth
well before we were saying that some
women are delusional
I'm not saying that I'm not saying
I'll say it pretty no
but I'm eating you I never said that oh
yeah sorry sorry sorry what did you say
I said I wouldn't compare myself I never
said Rihanna is not PR is um oh she's
not prettier than me I would never say
that I've not I just can't compare
myself and you said if you have if you
had to yeah
exactly so that's what I'm saying I
wouldn't say she's pretty exactly so
that's why I'm so it's very pretty
wait wait wait wait wait but that's why
I'm saying that before we were saying
that some of the women are a little bit
Yeah
guys guys okay okay um but you see this
is this like honestly I'm not even
trying to be rude you just proved my
point it's not women are delusional yeah
yeah
I'm not even saying you're not like I'm
not even trying to insult your looks
it's just it's Rihanna
we got to this party okay
dramatic because she can't sing in real
life I'm sorry but you're gone
okay she can't sing live I'm sweaty I
she can't sing like she's fit me
say I don't this is
that rate themselves higher and they
have nothing to offer but I'm just here
to tell you ladies and gentlemen I'm not
one of them
but you can understand every single
person
but you can understand why some people
might think it's delicious
but that goes back to me I'm a
millionaire I'm a millionaire but if you
don't have money in the bank account it
doesn't matter
just because just because like like I'm
sorry I'm not in China but times get
modeling contracts they're in Hollywood
okay
they could be in a small town in the
middle of nowhere Hollywood will find
tons okay there are people out there
that can sing they're not singles
let me back you let me back you
know
yeah
so just because like everybody's saying
something doesn't mean everybody was
taking certain tests and stuff recently
and you get me like they was all wrong
so just because everybody's saying stuff
it doesn't mean it's the truth okay
like everyone uh Rihanna
okay me personally
I'm not a fan of makeup
not that like I'm gonna be real if
yeah
whoever said that I want to talk like
that's that's a bit of insecurity there
but we won't talk about that but listen
my personal preference my personal
preference if I see a girl if I see four
girls
the one that's not got makeup on I'm
gonna look first or who has less let's
say that so you can't really be on
audience she's prettier than this she
prettier than that you're all capping in
it because really and truly like you
know right how if she rates herself more
than Rihanna then boom but I think
everyone as well is confusing pretty and
sexy
[Music]
Rihanna is sexier than most girls
wait wait what's the difference between
pretty and sexy I'm gonna get into that
let me hear it pretty is your face like
that's how somebody looks at your face
and say oh like if I if we if you're all
everyone's all dressed up in like you
can't see nobody then like who are we
picking who are you picking sexy is the
whole picture
can I add to you what you just said
because yes I think the the I've lost my
channel
I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats um blessing if you wanna okay okay
okay guys um thank you for the super
chats these are all going towards a
monopod um for blessing basically that
is when we go out and do Street
interviews we want to up
okay he muted my mic for a second okay
we want to up the production quality of
Street interviews so um I think it like
balances the camera I don't even know
I'm sorry guys okay so um like the video
make sure you guys are liking the video
and we have over 2 000 people in here
watching live so it is really important
that you guys like that as the number
one metric that YouTube uses to push out
this content okay Alistar Horton
everyone thought the Earth was flat
before and look how that ended Stephen
Roberts they're all average they can't
compare themselves to celebs or
millionaires when they aren't
accomplished or good looking it's very
delusional attraction is determined by
others not yourself jrab GC and team
energy Pearl love the show but please
for the love of God stop saying over
talking you should be saying stop over
to oh stop talking over me this is
eighth grade English Gus yes we want we
want pick me girls boss babes are
masculine AF we don't care about your
money status and success we don't care
about your money status success we want
no 304s femininity complicit compliant
fit and from family a silly sausage
material maternal age impacts the
success of IVF 31 in women younger than
35 24 in women age 35 to 37 16 in women
age 38 to 40 men's minimum cost is 30
grand up to 30 grand up to 120 Grand
major leaves sperm bank lock Charles
animam men can control fertility with an
implant structured like a inline
Shredder inserted into a tube leading to
the prostate gland invest saved flights
um samay and Tang um the blonde girl on
the couch is the most wifey
um domain keeper the baby is always
planned only by the woman um Charles
animam men um option to be fertile see
the movie children of men having
children if you are past your birthing
prime a fellow woman who is in the same
situation to marry and petition and to
adopt children major leagues then claim
Legacy versus genetically you
that they claim Legacy versus
genetically you want work here here
works when you give birth to one son or
daughter you stay with that same person
here's why the umbilical cord of the
second Offspring can save the child from
diseases also avoid AIDS and HIV
the UK Economist do your guests know
that our nation needs a certain
percentage of babies to replace future
taxpayers our economy and social Care
Systems and dependent on future are
dependent on future taxpayers Alistar
Horton most women are emotionally
unstable at the best times at the best
of times when they are pregnant it's
like they get a different hormonal
hormonal injection every day at least
the Savvy ninja I grew up thinking I
would have kids got to be an adult and
started rethinking it after I passed 35
years old snip snip no kids Legacy can
be carried on Beyond just last name and
children Gus we are put on this world to
procreate selfish 304s Josh Nixon when
birth control was invented studies and
tasks were conducted
when birth control what was invented the
studies and tests conducted were
inhumane and only being made for women
so that
so for that happened today that the test
for male birth control would be against
the law Doug MPA it's easier to stop one
egg each month than millions of sperm
for a man they haven't perfected a way
to stop the Little Swimmers constantly
um domain keeper they belong to the
streets Gus the status demo of people
the saddest demo of people in the west
are 40 plus year old women making 50k a
year no family and kids menopause can
begin as early as 40 and you're on 100
times more emotional domain Keeper Girl
your eggs are gone already Let me
refresh the page one second
um okay
um the one in the black is so insecure
she's afraid to contend with the reality
that she severely mid the only girl who
isn't is um the only girl who isn't kid
is the one who isn't fully mid with a
blonde with the tattoos Dennis
um bat matcher big fan how do I get on
your show you DM the pregame show
um Dylan chilling women in the black is
an example of the delusion of the women
she's a Four Tops and the Blondie in the
middle is certainly is most certainly
not in a solid four without makeup uh
the bikini bottom of course the gray
shirt in the back and the mummy Gad on
the left of the couch are loud and crass
their rude and masculine no commitment
will find you Alistar oh I read that one
Let me refresh it one more time and then
we'll go back to the show also guys like
the video there should be over a
thousand likes on this video
um we are at 607 the next time I look we
better be at a thousand there are over 2
000 people watching live
um I'm sorry guys I know I'm not good at
reading the super chats okay
um okay so we have why don't we
introduce the new faces on the panel
um we basically got a whole new panel we
had overbooking tonight so
um China you want to start
oh we have to unmute the mics
okay go ahead yeah I'm on a new face I'm
not I mean just introduce yourself for
the people that don't know you okay um
what kind of listen uh my name is China
The magnum's Voice uh
yeah
it's nice to be on the show again
shout out to you over there
uh my name is Bonnie
29. thanks for writing on the show okay
go ahead hi I'm Ruth
um I'm 40 and I'm a mom okay hey guys
it's Miriam it's been nice to be back
MK
nice if they're gonna share it blessing
can one of them go there
if they're gonna share somewhere some oh
is she coming back okay that's fine
that's fine
okay
um
okay so
um
let me go back to the questions
okay so going back to Jennifer Aniston
would you guys consider having a child
by yourself
if you couldn't find a partner
absolutely you know no not okay
um
no because I want my child to have a
father figure okay what about you
similar reason I want to give my child
the best opportunity so okay
I think I think it's quite obvious I
don't want children okay
in the back no I wouldn't no well I have
a child
um by myself but um I wouldn't do it
again I wait until I'm married okay
um what made you guys say that why
wouldn't you because a lot of people are
considering IVF nowadays and having a
child on their own
yeah I just think
when I look at my own life I feel like
it would have been completely different
without a father figure and I think
as much as big up to like single moms
and stuff they want to give that to
their child I think there are certain
qualities as a woman that you can't give
a child because you're not a man and I
feel like with for example when you get
into puberty and stuff as a child you
have very different combos with your mom
than you have with your dad and you take
away things from both of them and I feel
like that's Irreplaceable you can't give
the same advice as a woman because you
simply don't have the same brain as a
man so yeah what about you guys mine um
is just from my own experience like my
parents are still it's actually their
anniversary today 34 years pick them up
um and I just think I've grew up in that
environment of having like a loving
family and being supported as a loving
family so I can't imagine kind of not
giving my children that it's like maybe
it's the white picket fence fantasy that
I have but that's how I kind of want my
future
I just don't want to give put any child
in position where like the other ladies
have said they're going to be like
just basically not have the influence of
a father figure pretty much that yeah
me personally I I think see it from the
perspective of I would never have a
child out of wedlock like I would have
to be married just preference morals
whatever whatever so if I was to never
get married or never get to that point I
wouldn't bring a child into this world
yeah just every child needs a mother and
a father obviously situations and things
happen that that is not the case but I
think to go into it without you know
denying that child a mother or a father
or a father should I say it's yeah it's
selfish I was about to ask do you guys
think it's selfish women that do that
um depends this is for the men too you
guys can yeah it depends on their
situation
that depends on what I mean the
situation is there's no doubt okay that
yeah
he isn't there it might not have been
the choice you know so okay let's let's
take me I don't have kids let's say I'm
35. would it be selfish in this
situation I'm 35
and I no prospects it's just you know my
DMs are a desert it's horrible
and so I say you know what I I want a
child so I'm gonna go to the IVF clinic
and I'm gonna do it or I'm gonna I don't
I don't know I don't know the science
behind it the
I don't think it's selfish but I think
you need to think about you know what
can you offer the child can you because
you want your child to grow up in
certain conditions right so do you have
enough money to provide for the child do
you have maybe have a male figure around
you
um maybe your brother your dad that can
still support your child as a man so you
don't think it's selfish to expect that
out of them no because again before you
have a child I would have locked that in
I would have already like thought about
these things do I have money for this do
I have men around me that can support my
child that can offer that guidance if I
don't then I'm then I may not have a
child because
again it's a life you want to offer
someone the best life that you can give
right if I'm not in that position I'm
not going to have a child okay what do
you guys think well you said no
prospects so I'd say that's kind of
selfish
that's what you really bring into the
table is like oh as a soul person you're
not really bringing like the love and
the support you might be able to to a
certain extent but by yourself that's
hard like I wouldn't really want to wish
that on someone okay I think if it's a
choice
for you to bring a child into this world
by yourself and then look after the
child by yourself I think that is
selfish because yeah
and what about you China yeah I'll just
I was just waiting to see if anyone's
gonna say it wasn't selfish but yeah
it's incredibly selfish to to bring a
child into the world and do it by by
those types of means yeah okay
I feel like
I feel like having a kid in general is
kind of selfish even though you
mentioned Pearl earlier you said that
having not having a kid was selfish I
think like having a kid is inherently
quite selfish let's take a moment to
think about the world that we live in
today let's think about politics let's
talk about financials let's think about
everything that comes into being an
adult in the world that we live in today
the lowest rates of poverty ever in
human history yeah but human history is
[ __ ] first of all like let's think about
it comparatively I mean if you genuinely
really genuinely want children of course
you can have children but if you're
having children because you feel like
you need to that's different what's
wrong with the like the world today is
great especially in the west it is
better than it's ever been but it's
really awesome it's phenomenal so were
your parents selfish for having you
they're rubbing my face all the time no
Mom's asking you no I think they are how
many siblings do you have I have two so
there's three of you so your parents
were incredibly selfish for having you
guys and the thing is I feel like my
parents do have a lot of regret in terms
of having children especially so so you
wish she wasn't alive do you feel like
you feel like you don't want to be alive
that's not what I'm saying because
before a fetus is born they don't even
know what life is that's what I'm asking
you said it's incredibly selfish and
you're saying but I'm saying you come
from a family of three
um so do you consider your life to be
selfish I'm not gonna say on [ __ ]
camera that I wish I was dead there's no
need to swear we're just having a
conversation
but no but you're swearing the
conversation something is quite rude I
wasn't trying to be rude I was just
swearing like I normally taught I know
but it's not quite we'll see okay so
when you when you meet someone you've
never met somebody for the first time to
swear it when you speak to that person
with considered to quite rude so we're
on a platform and we're talking to like
a thousand thousand people that you're
using towards that it's like it's
[ __ ] Ruth I'm not gonna lie
to me okay
I've just literally just spoke I haven't
done anything you're beating her guys
have I raised my voice no bro have I
said anything derogatory wait hold on a
second wait you're stopping me it's
really rude
how much that she's alive no I asked her
a question I asked a question I asked a
question you keep interrupting so
nothing about my turn so the problem so
what we seem to find is when men speak
and when we speak directly we always get
women that try to speak to us about a
tone there's nothing wrong with my
tongue I haven't raised it she literally
just said it so could you just could you
check your friend put oh check the lady
next year and say there's nothing wrong
with his home you can check your
direction no but the thing is no but the
thing is directly if you want to no but
the thing is I am and everyone now
you're raising your voice no because
that's rude that's the time so what
you're doing is yeah you're gaslighting
the situation this is what you women
this is not what no no no no no this is
like yes
no no let me teach you I think I think
the question was a bit wow but that's
why we're on a podcast the question is
so what you guys are doing again you
guys are stopping the man from speaking
I tried several times on this platform
to speak oh now I'm waiting not you but
what you've done is first of all you
Gaslight that situation by saying about
my tone I didn't raise my tone I didn't
speak another word see what you're doing
again see guys guys so so this is a so
this is a good platform so I want a
super chats to look at look at this this
one this is an example of gaslighting I
simply asked the question because you
said it was selfish for um for people
from having children right now so I
asked her do you consider it to be
selfish for your parents that had you as
a child
um she was you know thinking about it
that's fine I had to think about it but
she swore at me so I've never met this
lady it's the first time I met her and
she sworn at me so I just said could you
please answer me on a platform what
you've then said to me is about my tone
if anything I would actually be quiet in
my right if someone swore at me so bro
what she actually responders just said
she's naturally swears anyway so so as
much as you're in your willing your rats
to be offended by what she said because
you don't know her you don't know
yourself your own person you have your
boundaries okay so you're allowed to
feel the way you feel
do you think the world owes you any
understanding so if you've never met
someone in your meeting for the first
time do you think the world owes you
understanding to be like I can just if
I'm blind at you do you think I owe you
understanding
no you've never been to East London I'm
not saying in the world necessarily owes
her understanding she just said that to
almost like
to comfort you like it's all right I
didn't mean it so let's use this example
right guys so let's use the example
right there's nothing wrong so there's
nothing wrong with my tone I haven't
raised my tone I haven't pointed at you
I haven't shouted at you okay okay no no
he's in it it's easy it's easy I mean he
was doing she she's like he did yeah she
I didn't so so you know what it is you
know what it is I find it
so I don't I don't want to do this Pearl
but I'm going to say this as a black man
and I want to do that I find it this is
this is a scenario that that we find
ourselves in I haven't done anything I
haven't shouted at you I haven't been
aggressive to you I've been sworn at you
but yet you no but what yet you have
continued to talk about my tone you've
tried to create an image of me Perpetual
image of me on screen which is not that
I was sworn to on live on the air that's
all I said was can you please not sweat
no no it's fine but we're not talking
about you now what we're talking about
is her gaslighting a scenario and she's
spoken about about the tone she's trying
to act like I've been aggressive to her
guys the super chats and everything will
let you know because I really haven't
done it you guys have jumped on top of
me but it's fine I'm ready for this
let's go ahead switch the situation
if we switch the rate they're not the
races the genders here if a girl says
that to a guy could you please not swear
at me it wouldn't be a thing and like
and that's the thing whenever men have
standards they're ashamed for having
standards constantly yeah it wasn't a
thing in the first place he said I swore
at him I'm swearing as I talk the way I
talk occasionally I'm actually a [ __ ] or
[ __ ] too bye mistake like I'm just
having a conversation because I feel
like a little bit more comfortable if
you don't want me to swear at you that's
completely fine it was quite simple I
simply said and I just made you aware of
it I didn't actually get at you I just
simply said could you please not swear
at me you don't know you weren't aware
of it but what happens from there I
can't believe what's happening it's just
simply a man saying please don't swear
at me and you guys have used it as a
situation to Gaslight instead about my
tone and even if I did lose lose my rag
a little bit why are you swearing at a
man that you've never met before in the
first time on a platform is very
disrespectful he was not swear no no no
no no no right now this is not even
about this no no no because I'm not
actually offended by what you said I
just simply said you could please not
swearing me said okay that's cool what
she's then gone on to do is create a
whole separate scenario now and I want
to know why have you done that I was
sticking up for her because I felt like
the question just was a little
insensitive to say that just the way it
was so you don't think I was I was in my
right to ask her considering she said
I'm not about the swearing I understand
no no about the swearing she said that I
just said being selfish right so I just
said do you consider your existence and
your siblings existence to be selfish
based upon the question that she put out
there I simply just gave a counter
question it wasn't the way it was how
was it worded it was no no I'm sorry no
no no no because this is an example no
we're not going to do this because what
you women do is you man you might guess
like you guys gas like men and then we
when we actually want to prove a point
you're like let's move it on We're not
gonna move it on I want to know no
because I want to know what what led to
the point where you can start saying
about my tone and start a disrespect
what led to it what did I say to her you
said to her about do you wish that you
weren't alive or something along them
lines it was worded that way and I just
thought oh that's a little bit too much
but that came after the fact that she
said she considered it to be selfish
I do think the question was a bit whoa
and we're all in that
after what she had said I wouldn't be
like why are you asking me that it makes
sense because even me I was kind of like
yeah do you not want to be here
sometimes I have my days so
so I don't think personally but I can
see why someone else might be a bit like
I don't know you whoa she understands so
even if she threw in the little the
little [ __ ] or whatever
I was a bit taken about that you took it
okay okay
let's go stop stop we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna stop stop you just did
it again okay we're gonna move on um do
you guys back road you guys think it's
selfish to
um
get IVF treatment
um and become choose to be a single
mother go ahead
in the corner yeah yeah go ahead yeah
yeah okay you think it's selfish what
about you
I understand why people would do it but
yeah just denying without a father in
the pictures
oh it's not fair yeah it's selfish
because ultimately every woman will try
to locate a man that can fill that
further figure or teach certain things
that the partner or the husband or
whatever would have taught if they were
within a union so it is selfish oh
personally I don't think you're selfish
if you have a good support system it
works well for you okay
okay that's one word yeah what about the
sperm donor though but there's still a
father involved to have that for that
child to be created there's still a
father involved there's a sperm which
comes from her father
I know but most most women right now are
single but they have a good support
system that makes the child uh even
better he works out for the child better
but if you have no support no no it
doesn't no no I said I said most I
didn't say everyone I think that's a
word because there's a lot of a lot of
women you can have a child if you want a
baby I don't think that's inherently
selfish when you put it your kid at
every statistical disadvant no no
offense to the single mothers on the
piano you can get every statistical
disadvantage if you talk to people that
came from single mother home say I want
a father you're more likely to go to
prison you're more likely to end up
homeless you're more likely to go to
jail like like every you're more likely
to drop out of school run away from home
I already said I think inherently having
children is a bit selfish but that's
besides that's the precise
please why would you push
I'm saying I'm saying original if you
genuinely want a child and you think you
have the facilities the money the
support system everything required other
than the male figure required to have a
children and you really really want a
child it's selfish but you can do do you
do you know I think a father figure is
required I think you can live you can be
a good [ __ ] person without a father
figure so why do you inherently need one
because me personally I'm big on family
my family supports each other around so
I'm saying support system I'm talking
about aunties uncles they all get
involved it's not just the fact it's not
just it's not just the father only that
still does my place so far but it
doesn't replace the further figure but
it helps I know the support system is
support it's not like the actual helping
you need like the father is not there
but you're being supported by people
around you okay so it makes it easier
for you yeah okay so but that still
doesn't replace having a father in there
he does he does either so it's going to
be selfish if women choose to not not to
be able to have a father and then go
still going to have a child that's
inherently selfish and what Paul said
all the statistically disadvantage so if
we look at especially if we look at
what's happening now in London a lot of
the knife crime a lot of the stabbers
and what's going on look at who's doing
it and when you when you look at all the
kids that come from single parent homes
I had a good support system so how about
that yeah but what I'm trying to say to
you is yeah when you so so exceptions
don't cancel out the rule so I'm glad
that you've done well but if you look at
statistics of what's going on not
everyone's like you no everyone's like
me but I'm saying Carl Champions people
I'm from South Africa most my myself can
culture background everyone we know each
other to be supportive of each other
together it's not just a child it's not
just the one person it's a whole
Community raising the child it's not
only you it's not the father would you
would you have preferred to have a
father figure I'm okay with myself right
now no but you didn't answer would you
have preferred it I can't have a
preference because I don't know why it
used to happen wrong okay yes or no
would you have preferred it no because I
like my life right now okay okay it's
crazy
I just want to quickly say yeah a lot of
people understand the idea of raising a
child you know you need to have like a
trap you need to have loads of people
around you that has no correlation with
having not having a father figure I feel
like there's a difference between
support and having a tribe to raise your
child because it takes more than one
person you need the aunties you need the
friends you need the cousins the
siblings whatever it may be but a father
figure a father period is something that
is irreplaceable when it comes to a
child especially when they're young
foreign
is it wrong to make a child with someone
that is clearly going to be a deadbeat
dad yes that's selfish yes wow so if I
if I was talking to some dude that just
got out of prison
okay okay I just don't believe most
women there's some sort of red flag that
they either yeah I don't most girls
aren't blindsided yeah and they usually
choose some so that's why I said it's on
you know I'm sorry they saw me it's not
on me like you saying it's selfish it's
just one-sided some people feel
different as well bro I'm happy that
you're here in it we're all happy that
you're hearing it what happened yeah
I'm happy yeah God bless the universe
appreciate it if your dad was a waste
man then that's not your fault but
that's your mom's fault end of the day
is weak we always put onus on the men
but these women pick these guys and most
of the time okay cool there's a small
position
so it's because we're 100 in control of
birth yeah 100 like when you said
stop interrupting me when you're 100 in
control of who is born you have more
responsibility more we have more power
that comes with more responsibility you
are responsible for who gives birth so
you you have free abortion up to six
months I'm responsible as well of of
having like sex with a woman that's what
they can give back as well
as soon as you have sex without
contraceptive you're also just as
involved in the pregnancy
that's not true because the only thing
he has control of is a condom and that
could break where you girls can steal it
the NBA had to issue statements saying
these women are stealing companies wait
wait we we're you can get an IUD that's
99.5 effective you can get birth control
if that doesn't work you can get the
Plan B pill if that doesn't work you can
take the abortion pill if that doesn't
work you get an abortion up to three
months there's no excuse I'm this I'm
not disagreeing with you they are
outliers but you're talking about art
lives
if you wear a condom properly
99.95 we're gonna get the girl pregnant
so this okay no the thing is we're
talking about mandam here in London
we're talking about okay oh you know
what the rubber don't feel though
doesn't feel good yeah
okay okay but that's but let's let's
take the condom example okay you can say
you cannot have sex with me unless you
have a condom on yeah that women are in
control of sex we are in control and who
has more power the one who has 41 for
wait who has 41 forms of birth control
are the one who has won less more power
let's also think about with societal
pressures when it comes to women no
don't roll your eyes because it's a fact
now but babe these Quantum things are
true because no no these people there's
a lot of people that carry this boosting
things
but it's just true like to be honest
it's not only about pregnancy here yeah
if you don't wear a condom this you can
be called Lydia chlamydia you can get
gonorrhea you can get anything you know
so that's kind of on you and if you then
like some people they play Russian
roulette with this pill yet
um they literally skip four days and
they're like four pills in and then they
get pregnant then it's sent you know
like if I don't choose to keep the child
you know like that's a thing and also
like I feel like a lot of people get
their emotions caught up in this thing
like let's say yeah you're with your
boyfriend you know it's been cheating
and then you get pregnant and then your
emotions get involved you're like oh but
he's so cute on his good days
maybe it could work it's never gonna
work because he's been cheating so or
you know if it's just not the ideal
situation then you as a woman
how much is you cannot like it you still
choose to have the baby even though the
situation is not perfect same with the
condom thing right if a guy comes at
your house you know you're doing your
thing and then it's it's time to put the
rubber on and you're and you're like oh
I'm in the moment and something happens
that's your body that's you not being
sacred with your body as much as you
dislike it
it's true because you have to deal with
the consequence you just I agree you do
actually have to deal with the
consequence which is very unfortunate
but I think it's
I think of course there is lame when it
comes to women you have made a choice to
have sex without a condom 100 you have
allowed religion or whatever societal
cultural influences affect how you feel
in terms of abortion or contraception or
whatever but I still feel like if you're
having sex with a man and he says I
don't want to have a condom and you're
like you know okay fine I don't want to
have a condom either but he also chose
not to use a Content yeah
can I can I ask you a question I'm gonna
ask you a question okay so say all right
say you have sex and you get pregnant
okay who who controls who gives birth
who whose choice is that what what after
you're pregnant who whose choice is it
I have a question for you do you know I
need to answer that question no that's
fine I need you to okay yeah women give
birth cool no no no no who's in control
of whether you keep it or give birth
yeah that's fine okay I agree with that
of course you have the baby okay so of
course you're gonna be the one so you
agree that women have more who have
control over who is born a hundred
percent control oh of course okay okay
what's your what's your question and
then I can someone said something about
being selfish wait wait bro like if a
woman has 100 control over who get or
who gets born right yeah you have no
control of that so yeah I understand so
if you so if a woman gets pregnant yes
and and you want that baby I have no
saying that okay cool and then if you
don't want that baby you still have no
say in it yeah how is that not 100
controlling selfish no I'm saying if the
girl wants to have the baby right how is
that selfish if she has a baby and she
feels like it's right well if you don't
no because I don't have any control in
this yeah
for me personally if I'm to have sex
with someone and I'll take all the
responsibilities I'm having sex with you
if I have a baby with you then I'm gonna
take all that
nobody can have to you if you don't want
to you though and she decides to have to
you but my [ __ ] you have sex without a
contact
but the point is we we have more power
yeah we have we so so if we are going to
get more power it comes with
responsibility having more of the
responsibility because the man the men
have one choice condom or no condom we
can't we can we know when we're
ovulating you know when you're you
should
wait wait and you you have the choice
you get who gets to chew all right all
right wait who gets to choose whether or
not they're on birth control men or
women women who gets to choose whether
or not we take the plan B men or women
women who gets to choose when if if you
have sex on or off your when you're
ovulating men or women who has the
choice to track their cycle men or women
women who has the choice to get an
abortion women women okay so that's
that's the point
who has who has the choice to have sex
is two people right so as soon as soon
as your
um consent into having sex
okay okay yeah okay sex is is
reproduction so from the time that you
lay down with a woman from the time a
woman lies down with a man there's a
possibility that is
listening to what I said no no I hear
what you're saying I do hear what you're
saying but I said women are in control
of who is born yeah men are like who
after I understand that the sex they
both get to pick but after the sex it is
a hundred women are in control yeah but
also but do you not think that the the
guy from the time that he is the woman
who should have the responsibility
I think I think when women have 10
choices we can make to avoid that
situation and men have one there's more
responsibility on us and also but I'm
saying a man has responsibility for life
do I do I think men should just shoot
like I've heard some stories or y'all
don't even pull out I'm like you're
crazy
and I do I do I recommend that no but at
the end of the day we have 10 choices
they have one maybe maybe two if you
include
women have more responsibility that's
all you're saying okay
with all the points you've made yes 100
but I just want to know at what point do
we draw the line and actually say that
like that because well even let's take
an irresponsible man let's take a baby
daddy let's take Nick Cannon that's
that's okay
wait wait wait wait wait okay okay
arguably irresponsible are you happy
okay yeah okay okay
so that's one arguably sexually
irrespect responsible man that's 10
sexually irresponsible women absolutely
so again it's more on like there are
more sexually irresponsible women than
there are sexually irresponsible men
because you guys might not know this but
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year
where the majority of women are sexually
active and there are more STD cases than
ever before yeah that's more out of
wedlock pregnancies than ever before
there's more abortions I actually I'm
not 100 sure I think there's more
abortions than ever before and and so
it's like is it on the men when most of
men aren't sleeping around that much
most men only around 20 percent of men
can really sleep around like that and
then so then it comes back to the women
because who are we picking to sleep with
yeah because also most people
if I took if I know most guys I know
they like to sleep without I feel like
most people let's be honest like to
sleep without condoms right but at the
end of the day
let's say you meet a guy on a party and
you choose to sleep without economy you
don't know what he's been doing he might
have been in London Birmingham Rio de
Janeiro Paris Amsterdam he's been
everywhere and you let him enter that's
not only about you let him maybe getting
pregnant that's about you being
irresponsible with your body and I feel
like a lot of people need to come to
terms with themselves and think you know
what this is my body because at the end
of the day
women for example with chlamydia a lot
of women don't know that they have it
let's say yeah you get chlamydia you
don't get checked up often you might get
infertile that's on you because you
chose to let someone enter your body
without a condom that was your choice
and I have a question just just and
ladies hopefully we can be honest here
how many of you have a guy in your
friend zone that you know would date you
and would be a good guy and would be
there long term raise your hand if you
do raise your hand if you do raise your
hand a good guy do you know what date
you take you you don't have one none no
they are smart they wouldn't date me no
none okay okay
yeah three three okay yeah so it's like
no no no can I just touch on what you
said about the about the Russian
roulette with the pill see like I will
only sleep with someone without a condom
unless like I'm kind of with them and
that's that's the thing and I know
they're not with it and if they've been
checked yeah yeah yeah okay but if I
forget my pill like say a one day two
day I don't play Russian Roulette I'll
openly say to him look I forgot my pill
we need to wrap up be careful because
that's my response yeah because I've
also heard these stories where girls
I'm sorry but nothing against women but
this to me sounds so [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
I'm swearing sorry this sounds so weird
in my head where girls lie yeah and they
say their own contraception I'm thinking
what are you doing it's happened to a
lot of my mouth I just don't get it
you're literally playing with fire I
have a question for the men do do any of
you guys know a guy that's happened to
yeah loads of people 100 just I'm just
curious like men in the back men in the
back so there's five six minutes seven
men raise your hand if you know someone
that's happened okay mom okay so all
right Simon and then you too you do so
so it's called which goes back to we
have more power because they look at all
of these guys know somebody where the
women lied and said she was on birth
control and that in that instance I have
a question did he really have a choice
no he doesn't no can I can I say
something right power no power every
action is a consequence you have to
really take the consequence regardless
I'm sorry yeah but that's kind of her
point
in that scenario obviously I'm not going
to take owners of the man because I'm I
don't I'm not going to trust the woman
straight away because this is the
easiest way to get trapped and if you've
got something about you and if you're
worth anything then you're not gonna be
you're gonna take some some steps right
but once again what you're doing is
you're you're not you're not placing any
blame on the women you're saying the man
is everything when we don't have the
choice so if if the choice is taken away
from for most men then you can't really
put the blame firmly on on most men so
my thing is this like so you meet women
that are single mothers and for from us
men we look at single mothers and two in
two scenarios baby mothers and single
mothers if you were married and then you
were divorced or your Widow would look
at you as a single mother
um if you was just had a baby by some
guy situationship whatever it was we
look at these are baby mama so men we
treat we treat women different so when
we're out now we meet a lot of baby moms
outside and then we look at you like
where's your baby father and a lot of
times you can't get typically higher
than your baby father so what tends to
happen is you you guys have gone on bred
by some guy and you might not speak
highly of him you might say all these
types of things but then we think about
oh my gosh that's the guy you chose to
give the highest honor to so when you're
outside now and you're trying to think
you can level up level up your level and
you're saying oh you don't want to
settle what you actually don't want to
do is you don't want to realize what
your actual realistic level is and this
is the problem for a lot of baby mothers
so I can I just ask them a question are
you would you judge a Woman based on
their previous partners that what you're
saying 100 facts
it's like I have a question for the man
and this is just something I've heard
and tell me if this is true would you if
a girl has an ax that you you think is
like trash like absolutely waste what do
you guys say waste man here
um do you guys is she like tainted yeah
100
100.
that goes both ways I don't think it
does so I'm sorry I'm sorry there's a
lot of men
there's a lot of there's a lot of men
are women lining up to date Drake even
though he had a baby with a cornstarch
but it depends on the person but I feel
like if you look at yourself yeah and
the person you date is a kind of a rep
what you said is is a reflection of you
I do agree so if if someone that you
know has dated someone
um and you don't really like that person
I'm thinking to myself why are you
associating yourself with that person
because that's a reflection on you I
definitely I agree I do agree and that's
why your point about the whole league
thing that we spoke about before I did
semi-agree but there are liars in this
world and there are people that are
manipulators and they can they're really
good
I'll give you I'll give you one I'll
give you one no no no no no I'll give
you I'll give you one toxic X I'll give
you one liar that just Bamboozled you
yeah right I'll give you I'll give you
one because I'm sorry I'm sorry like
three
then you're toxic 100. so yeah
it's not like can girls have one it
depends how bad did you make a kid with
that
but but when it becomes a pattern it's
like you didn't get bamboozled every
single time
bro you have three different babies
not because I feel like I've been in a
place I feel like before where I wasn't
happy Within Myself and I feel like you
attract a certain kind of person now
when I look back and I now
and in a more comfortable position with
myself with my career the people I'm
around I look at people completely
differently there's different kinds of
people around me so I feel like in the
past I've allowed situation and it's
it's a hard one to take because you're
like I was the person that did that but
I've allowed certain people in my life
and I ignored my gut feeling and that's
on me I can be the victim I could be
like oh they treated me badly yeah but
the first time they treated you badly
you went back and you let them do it
again okay you let them do again you
need to sometimes just be like you know
what I'm a [ __ ] yeah maybe you treated
him badly too yeah like it takes two to
tango yeah exactly that's a conversation
like women always want to talk about oh
my lying cheating ex but why did he
cheat most men aren't looking to cheat
what were you not doing at home I'm
serious
I'm
seriously but then also I'll give you
again again I'll give you one one
sometimes there are some friends in my
life but I'm just like time after time
after get again you're in the same
situation with another guy he's just a
different guy same same person doing
treating you the same way it's like
didn't you learn from the last time and
that gets boring and it it's definitely
is that person you are what you attract
but in life we have to expect that life
is biggest lesson is experience so you
have to go through yeah I disagree you
can't go through the same situation
multiple times no that's what I'm saying
because that kind of because if you
let's say because you're saying you have
to if every person you've dated let's
say has a different toxic trait then
it's different but most of the time when
I look at my um the reason why it wasn't
working out before I didn't have good
boundaries for myself yeah so I I allow
people to do things now that I've worked
on that and I'm actively working on that
that won't happen to me again but I have
to take responsibility in my past to be
like you know what I allowed that to
happen I allowed them to do that to me I
went back that's on me and I feel like a
lot of people nowadays because of this
cancer culture and everything they're
always like it's other people other
people yeah at the end of the day you
came on this Earth and you need to take
yeah you need to make choices and take
responsibilities
to end up pregnant and then you've got
someone that's judging okay okay yeah
but but you had 40 like then you had 10
choices that you didn't make that went
into that one child you were the plan b
you had birth control you had you had no
no so I'm saying it wasn't just one bad
decision it was like 10. that got you
you could only get pregnant like three
days a month and then back to the
cheating thing like it goes It goes back
to there's two different types of
reasons that girls keep getting cheated
on you either pick a top 20 Guy where
that girls are thrown at him all the
time and that's your choice like it kind
of goes back to I always say if you date
an NBA player or you know even I'll even
give you a basketball player out here if
you date one of them and you get you get
cheated on I don't really feel bad for
you you pick that's what you picked or
number two you're not doing something at
home it's hard for men to get sex so
like if you're not sleeping with your
man I don't feel bad if you get cheated
up well you know you know what it sounds
like to us like this just sounds like to
us like you spent your 20s chasing bad
boys getting one free chat in Tyrone and
then in your thirds or whenever it is
you decide that actually the results
wasn't as good you come out with a kid
yeah you come out more damage now and
now you start looking at guys you didn't
look so for us now it doesn't it's gonna
be so it doesn't sound like you know
what does it sound like we're getting
we're getting someone that's got more
trauma they might have children
um and then now what do I actually get
so so what what good is it to men I know
but no I was just saying based on what
you said before about sometimes if a
woman's got a toxic ex or someone who's
just trash basically you would look at
them and say you just basically not
you're not interested in them that'll be
a deal breaker for you so I was just
saying
for some people in some cases they have
they they go they make that one mistake
and you're saying they had 10 choices
but I go back to that point of can we
not can we can we not forget there are
people that really do they're good at
manipulating and acting like they are
one person up until whilst you're
pregnant like the lady we had on the
platform before
she said there were red flags yeah and
there may be but then you have to take
into account her age she also said she
was 21. so also she recognizes
you're 21. so I don't really think
that's young that's just my opinion
wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay so so on top of that she had the
choice to have a kid before you got
married or after you got married and she
could have said she could have said I'm
gonna have an IUD until I have a ring
she could have did that she didn't make
that choice she could have made the
choice to track her cycle she could have
made the choice to go on birth control
she could have made the choice to get an
abortion she could have made the choice
to pick a guy that didn't have all these
red flags but it's like 10 choices that
go into the one choice I'm not saying
she's a bad person I'm not like she's
beautiful I'm sure she'll like find
someone else but it's gonna be a lot
harder now and I understand why men
wouldn't want to deal with that have you
ever been a victim of fraud that online
fraud yeah
um you know I think that my venmo hacked
once
I've had this multiple yeah and you know
what you know and I would say when I got
my venmo hacked it was my own damn phone
because someone on the date is looking
like he's saying you've got a baby you
made the wrong choice and you have
simple choices and if someone said then
you are you're an idiot for doing that
yeah and I look at you right now yeah I
would say
I would say hey they probably could
steal from wait actually I'm not gonna
say that no but you can I let me quickly
just say something here because I feel
like I'm probably the youngest on this
panel
um I'm 21 in it and I understand my
value enough to understand that my
partner reflects my value on vice versa
so I would never really commit to
anybody that I
I know is
not not gonna match that to an extent
right also I think within understanding
my value I understand that for men for a
man to commit to a woman yeah and like
have that
it's a big thing like it is it takes a
lot for a man to really like knuckle
down and be like I'm gonna commit to
this person as well as commit to having
a child and being in the picture it's a
lot because men spread their seed and we
bear the kids do you know what I'm
saying so I think the fact that stuff
like that to me I've always naturally
understood that and
is being discussed where people don't
get it is really interesting to me like
I don't understand where the discourse
is with that
everyone's like
all right so question question for the
men for the men would you marry an older
woman knowing what we know about
pregnancy and infertility in older women
so would you get into a relationship
with a woman that was over the age of 35
that wanted kids and knowing this is a
possibility no
no okay tell me why China I feel like
you got thoughts
um because
geriatric pregnancy starts when does it
start age is it 30 29 30 it's not to
leave it I think geriatric starts at 35
but you've lost most of it yeah so you
lose most of X by 30 Joey actually
pregnant she starts at 35 I would like
to have three to five kids I don't have
any kids so far so I come from a big
family so um yeah I would obviously need
to be a woman that could that could
compare him yeah and you know what it is
like I'm just I'm just real man like
like I have to put this out there
because there seems to be some thing
that men don't understand as you get
older because I'm in my 30s and that
like things just get so much better so
it's like my girls and my girls in their
20s and that and I guess I get women all
the times in the 20s that have no
problems that would move to me so this
is something where so what tends to
happen is a lot of women in their 30s
because they they spend their 20s
chasing off the Chad and Tyrone and and
getting one through getting higher body
counts getting trauma getting kids or
whatever you're not so by the time they
get to their 30s and then they wake up
and they like the girl said before she
was having a panic attack or whatever
um they start looking at the guys that
they didn't look at but the thing is now
like these types of guys were not
actually looking at you and then if
you're out in the club store when you're
in the 30s there's a new set of women
that are out now from their 20s right
and and the guys you didn't look at when
you were chasing off the chat and Tyrone
and now the guys that you're chasing
after but they haven't access to all
types of women so a lot of times you
will get women that get in their
feelings to start saying stuff about oh
man and they thought he's trying to date
younger women or it's because they want
to control them and do all this no the
reason they're saying that is because
it's competition now and they're out in
the same exact same place and they're
going out for the same group of men and
so they want to make it fair but life
isn't fair when we was younger and I was
18 and 20s and that and they were dating
all the older man and they were popping
bottles and jumping in the cars like we
had to we had to take the pain it wasn't
nice they had the sparklers the uncles
were doing their thing but no it's cool
it's cool isn't Western they're the
sparklers and that they were jumping in
the whips you know we was watching what
was going on you know you know the
bottles yeah we went to very different
high schools yes no like one was out so
so we've seen all of that so now now
we're the uncles and we're living alive
and some people are are not happy but
the difference is a lot of the the
younger women they have seen what you
women haven't seen in these men that
you've missed and now you're directly in
competition with them so what I always
put out to people is you need to use
your your prime time from 18 to 28
you've had 10 years literally outside
like you've had good guys you've had
guys in your DMs guys stacking shelves
guys studying guys that you've aired but
you're chosen to go after the top 20 of
guys that have access to multiple women
guys that can have one baby with one
woman and then actually get you to have
babies with them again so my thing is
this is this you know things get so good
and we don't take baby mums around here
bro listen yeah hey let me say something
yeah because I come in really late yeah
listen listen listen let me say one
thing yeah I do not have sympathy for
you chicks yeah when you get old you hit
the wall and now you start complaining
oh where has all the good men gone bruh
you had the good man they're in your
friend zone in your best Years bro yeah
when you're tasting Channel Tyrone like
my boy said try to Tyrone yeah yeah
you're smashing guys like China and King
riches bro it's your football yeah and
then like at the end of the day bro it's
on you bro you're adult bro you know
what I'm saying you talk you chasing bad
boys and and drug dealers and rappers
and YouTubers and all of these kind of
people but at the end of the day you
only got yourself to blame fam are you
both single then what are you both
not even though no no no no no I'm
active I'm active I'll say I'm active
yeah are you single yeah why because I
want to be right now okay interesting so
anyway as I was saying yeah boom like
and then you get old and then boom like
your your options have dried up and
you've dried up as well that's it bro
you know what I'm saying and don't blame
no one in it don't cry in it because
when you was winning you didn't care
about nothing you know what I'm saying
you didn't care about the guys in your
friend zone you didn't care about the
guys that want to treat you right or
nothing bro because every man here has
had the situation where you like to go
and you was willing to give that girl
the world and everything and it was it
wasn't even a hypersexual situation it
you wanted to go on picnics hold hands
Skip and all of that rough yeah she
cheated on them with you
he changed the whole time but listen at
the end of the day you hurt feelings in
it so when the world comes and bites you
back bro it's bro you had your chance in
it that's all I'm saying in it did
someone hurt you I feel like this
classic
it got techy
let's ruin it no I'm good I'm Gucci
number one number one comment when
someone a man is speaking facts
I completely agree because when I
sometimes you know I used to sometimes
go to Mayfair clubs and then you have
the people with the tables and the
bottles
and it's just like yeah the sparklers
whatever like I'm just like cool
whatever it's always weirdos anyways and
you just stand there and then it's true
like most girls chase after these guys
but you can just tell by the way these
guys move like if there's 20 girls
they're probably more interested in
getting into gang bang bang bad boys as
well you like the bad guys
you've never had a bad boy face I've
I've had it before so
yes yes can I talk yeah of course you
can but I've realized that how old was
he when you realized
like two years ago how many years did
you leave bad boys for it was only when
I came to London
a year-ish but then I just realized it
wasn't for me because for me personally
what I look for in people and in friends
and stuff is way deeper than this you
know like I had an epiphany I hear that
I don't know I feel like I feel like for
you it's what you said it's like if you
really and truly look inside yourself
you want someone that really values you
these people that chase after multiple
people they're not in this space so if
you choose to are you talking about men
or women both ways because there's also
that's what that's what we like to do we
like to chase after multiple women we
like variety
some girls it's what you say they they
have the choice to be with the good guy
but they want to be with with someone
that it looks looks more attractive I
think I think I think that all girls
want a guy that other women want I don't
think there's a single girl that wants a
guy that nobody wants that's true no
that's true but what I'm saying is if
you if you do the look with if you do
the if you look within yourself yeah and
if you want someone that only wants you
yeah and you chase after people that
want multiple people that are valued by
multiple people then you make that
choice to get hurt because you see the
way they move and you don't tell me tell
your friends
but I've had this convert with many of
my friends where I'm like what did they
say when you say this to them oh they
don't like it but I don't care because I
need to speak the truth right and I'm
saying you're actively making the choice
to interact with these people and you
keep doing it again so you shouldn't so
you shouldn't have sympathy the same way
I don't have sympathy you shouldn't have
a sympathy as well yes we you see what
king Richie was saying here you was like
oh like like who hurt him but you have
to understand something yeah like he's
just representing all the men that he
speaks to no no like it's not right I
thought it's powerful no but it's nobody
you said to her yeah
the reason it's something that we
commonly get when we start speaking with
passion here they're like who hurt you
it's not that what hurt it's just that
we represent you recognize her
I love it so so we have to laugh because
it's like okay cool it was supposed to
be a laughable okay so what's so so once
we get past that it's like okay we're
not hurt but there's a lot of men that
we represent it's not it's not just you
like like this is just what women always
yeah like it's it's it's you guys say
things but you don't know how many times
you've heard this on the channel just
like you said you're representing a lot
of men and you're not necessarily hurt
yourself I've been sitting here talking
quite passionately about men being
delusional and Men lying and being
manipulative I'm not talking from a
place of hurt personally yeah I've had
one mess up I'm not even joking like one
mess up where with a guy with an idiot
guy okay and I like my lesson but well I
never said but I never said who hurt you
I know you didn't so I know you did that
but I just wanna I just want to clarify
that because I felt like I was
championing that a lot and I don't want
anyone to like not used I am not the
Egypt girl okay I'm not Deborah with the
same old repetitive guy okay but I know
a lot of women who have been
manipulative and I manipulated and
that's but I empathize with them is what
I'm saying I representing it's literally
just because women are dating the same
guy yeah again it goes back to only only
20 of men really get to pick another 80
or whoever whoever will take them so if
you choose to go after your top 20 guy
and he cheats sorry don't really feel
bad listen if you picked he wanted to be
over six foot you want him to make money
you want to be attractive you want also
to be obsessed with you it's like we've
been sold a dream it doesn't be fairy
tale [ __ ] that's not real yeah you're
kind of pulling the true symptoms in all
yourself yeah
um okay guys I'm gonna Read Super chats
and then I think we're going to close
out the show so have some final thoughts
um ready because we're going to do that
at the end
um guys thank you for all the super
chats um they are going towards
blessings monopod and like one round of
applause for this huge panel we had yeah
um okay guys
um shout out to Big Bree wait let me
refresh this really quick like the video
we better have over a thousand likes on
the video next time I check there better
be okay I can't even see also guys we
just hit 710k in a month and like yeah
yeah
we just hit 700 so um shout out to all
of you for making this possible okay
Lord Commander Lord Commander they use
the weightless fail fallacy the
difference between being able to afford
something and that thing just not being
available like a Rolls-Royce
um see Dumbledore I figured out a year
ago that I need to make better choices
says every 28 year old woman after she's
been ran through
um tell 92.65 no broad is single because
they want to be it's always because the
options they want don't want them it is
what it is who hurt you Lord Commander
when a woman says I choose to be single
that's woman needs for all the men I
really want don't want me Gus women
don't choose to be single only celibate
Vlad is strong something um
accountability and personable personal
personal
responsibility is Kryptonite to most
women those that have it can be
considered unicorns
Alistair Horton I will say it again
sympathetic doesn't contain simp and
pathetic by coincidence Casey F sack all
rise for a round of applause for King
riches
China and riches let's go which has got
real shout out king riches you always
have the most loyal fan that's why we
saw that that's what we thought that's
why we signed them at jpt right we got
to meet store okay
something
um how do I get on the show without any
social media do you still do email
um make an Instagram account and DM the
pregame show it's not that hard okay
blackest Panther abstinence is also an
option but modern women lack
self-control women think they can act
like men even five-year-olds understand
delayed gratification Maurice and tfiak
the guy in the black is really into his
feelings is an example of not having a
father figure in his life life
fatherlessness fatherless kids often are
emotionally unstable Maurice girl on the
black experience is not the best teacher
experience leaves you with scars learn
from other people's experiences blackest
Panther men and women are different
things in relationships go both ways
women control sex you are the one with a
womb not men the responsibility for
childhoods childbirth is yours as a
woman take responsibility nefarious Al
woman on the panel besides the one in
the black and the South African dude is
a typical single mother raised Sam
respect to China for holding frame black
is Panther great great conversation
these women these women saying that the
consequence of sex is a baby but can
choose to have the baby or not this is
why abortion needs to go no one should
get a choice you have sex you become a
parent period come on tell us again
about the societal pressures in the
privacy of a bedroom please
black is Panther this is what is
referred to as a son husband a man that
cannot accept the reality that he would
have been better off with a father in
his life black expand their perfect
example of woman acting like children
two dudes would not find that offensive
but women shout for equality and then
get offended when men treat or talk to
them like they would treat or talk to a
man lyrically incline um on the count of
three have all the women point to the
best looking woman in the room the UK
Economist so the lady wants to be an
engineer is she going to swear at her
employer and colleagues good luck with
that see Dumbledore her parents didn't
want kids she curses all the time who
would have guessed junkyard parents
create 304s KCF China wins finish her um
casual casual term yes yes the man is
not backing down let's go we found the
UK version of Myron KCF so swearing to a
stranger is acceptable wording big
Breezy she's gaslighting him he was
never he never raised his tone black is
Panther I answer calls for couples
therapy place and it's always men
wanting to save their relationship not
women zh you missed the Super Chat
earlier see Dumbledore blonde was an
eight
120 120 and 5 kilograms ago 5K less
makeup 20kg less weight and 100 kg less
attitude domain keeper ask the females
to rate themselves from one to ten and
don't use seven Doug MPA my G China in
the house about to drop some knowledge
your voice is needed in these modern
times get em Daryl follows don't want
standards that way they can't be held
accountable they love to play in the
gray area so they have plausible
deniability big Breezy the one in the
black is so insecure she's afraid to
contend with the reality that she
severely oh I read that one okay I'm
gonna refresh it really quick really
quick just to make sure there are no
super chats guys like the video there
should be over a thousand likes on this
video also guys
um I know I've said this before but I'm
gonna say it again 700 000 subscribers
in seven months is literally mad it's
literally mad
um I I know I said this last show but
I'm literally so great grateful to be
able to do something that I love and I
can't believe I'm here so thank you guys
so much
um Lord Commander I read that one okay
so um why don't we go around everyone
say final thoughts and if you have any
social media you want to plug feel free
to do that now so then go this way and
then the back row
um I thought it was a good convo I feel
like most people have spoken their
thoughts
um apart from that follow me on
Instagram My First Single is coming out
in
next month so um yeah Emma Robin music
on Instagram
thank you I enjoyed everyone's company
everything I say is light-hearted so
um and I just released a calendar so if
you want to follow me on Instagram it's
parishjetx also you'll catch some
pictures of me of no makeup and I look
great so thank you guys
it's been real it's been great yeah
yeah
it's been great
yeah I [ __ ] about um whole whole Vibes
my name is bunny Instagram funny Don
movie
that's me I'm good
yeah my name is China
um shout out to Pearl yo shout out to my
boy King riches for jumping in yeah to
obviously hold it down with me shout out
to all the the Chapman them chat to Doug
MPA blessing everybody down make sure
you follow me at my name is China
subscribe to YouTube got better love for
you Pearl yeah yeah yeah
obviously
I obviously King Rich are you not
already no bro King riches yeah how
about the videos you got coming out all
right tell them why they should
subscribe he got a bunch of videos It's
mad you know what you know why I was
late hey everyone listening you know why
I was late because I was out in short
ditch blood I was talking to the randoms
out there the drunk girls all of that
blood is my brother yeah asking them my
question all the questions you don't
want to ask but you're too shook yeah
I'll ask them yeah I'll ask them
straight to the face so obviously
there's a lot of uh good content coming
out yeah obviously reaction videos hey
hey top producer we got mad I'm mad
videos coming out as well so make sure
you go check out uh King riches that's
me my YouTube channel big up Pearl
obviously just plenty things so well
over 700k yeah yeah we're almost at 710
we just hit 700 like four days ago or
something like that mashing work yeah
he's almost at 50. he also does a live
show Fridays every Friday and all you
girls yeah I hate what these uh come to
my show isn't it like forget me I am not
scared of you so come to my show and
I'll pick up all right cool go subscribe
to the channel what's good okay go ahead
it's been sweet it's been a Vibe it's
nice to be back and yeah I enjoyed it
it's nice to be here
um didn't get a lot of air time but um
yeah I think my final thoughts would
just be that yeah it takes two to make a
baby and six creates babies so if you're
gonna have sex then there's a potential
there's gonna be a baby so that'll be my
final point and I didn't get to say
about my anti-abortion activist so you
can follow me and our work at CBR
underscore UK
okay guys
um like the video on your way out um
again there's 2 000 people watching I
think we should have 2 000 likes on the
video like it's free okay I'm not asking
y'all to Super Chat I'm asking you all
to like the video a couple announcements
before we end the show the first is that
we have two clips channels Pearl daily
and just pearly Clips we're almost at
200k on just pearly clip so make sure
you go subscribe also subscribe to wife
school
um when we get to a thousand subscribers
and we finish editing the video and
we're gonna drop episode one of wife
school so if you're at 304 and you want
to be a wife do you have me on IG just
partly things one will put you in wife's
school you're like I wasn't raised by a
wife I don't know how to be a wife look
at I'm bringing wives from across the
Nations I have so many people I have
Homemakers coming you can learn how to
cook you can learn how to clean you can
learn how to garden if you want to yeah
so DM me on Instagram anyways
um the four membership tiers we have um
first is a five dollar you get to be a
part of the chat second you get to be a
part of our Discord behind the scenes
blogs third you get to connect with me
on social media that means having access
to my inbox fourth that means you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month a
month I really recommend this if you
want to grow on YouTube or you have
questions about the show and how to do a
live show I could give you the template
um follow my Ig they banned my first one
so just probably things one
that's really sad
um they also Banned Me on Tick Tock but
so follow me just probably thinks dot
five and six
um
subscribe to wife school thank you for
the super chats and we'll talk to you
next time